Este es un banco de alimentos de Madrid
en España la mayoría de los que acuden
proceden de América Latina los migrantes
son los más golpeados por la inflación
50 y compramos un montón Ahora vas y no
compras nada ahorita gastamos el doble
el aumento de los alimentos ha sido
elevado considerable que se ha notado el
mensual que se llega a fin de mes con mi
mujer que mi mujer tampoco tiene un
trabajo estable
pues lógicamente a pedir y ya está eso
no llega es que no llegas no llegas
según la principal organización de
consumidores de España hasta mayo el
país registró Un aumento de precios
promedio anual del 15,2%. el mayor en 34
años esto ha provocado Un aumento en la
demanda de los comedores sociales
encontramos perfiles de gente más joven
gente más joven que lo que te comentaba
que está trabajando y no le llega el
dinero para poder adelante no tiene que
pagar el transporte tiene que pagar o en
la gasolina la comida la vivienda las
conocidas como colas del hambre han
aumentado un 30% y coinciden con que
cada vez hay menos donantes para los
comedores especialmente de productos
como leche y aceite toda la gente está
bastante limitada económicamente para
poder seguir tirando adelante cuanto
antes pues mira tenemos este dinero
vamos a utilizarlo en ayudar a esta
gente Pero ahora ni siquiera Ellos
tienen dinero algunos nos piden Perdón
después del descenso del precio de la
electricidad y el transporte la
inflación en España bajó por segundo mes
consecutivo este septiembre cayó hasta
un 9%. sin embargo los expertos auguran
un invierno complica